[Musique]
je suis alain dominique perrin je suis
président fondateur le président de la
fondation cartier
je suis président du jeu pomme et il
m'arrive aussi de collectionner un peu
l'art contemporain
et contrairement aux apparences je suis
un mec assez solitaire gp est seul
fa sol isolé en dehors du monde élite et
en dehors des machins c'est en ce que je
préfère
façon moi j'ai jamais habité
complètement nulle part pas ce moment je
passe mon temps en voyage
ça fait 40 ans que voyage
mon domicile les plus réguliers ces les
avions
alors moi j'ai des petits nuages de
malte et à lutter mais après
et voilà
il fait un temps de curé
mais si c'est ma balle dans ces mondes
c'est mon domicile
j'y viens beaucoup de manière très
irrégulière toi c'est vraiment en
fonction de mes entretiens parce que je
voyage beaucoup quand même
j'adore cet endroit et c'est un endroit
qui est vraiment fait pour accueillir de
l'art contemporain l'art que j'aime
c'est un art un peu encombrant il ya
beaucoup plus de grandes choses que les
petites choses donc il fallait que je
trouve quelque chose dans ce genre là et
j'ai eu de la chance
[Musique]
c'est une oeuvre que j'ai achetés en
chine sous un jeune un jeune artiste je
suis tombé complètement fascinée par ce
bonhomme et par ce travail et il ne
voulait absolument pas me le vendre
parce que lui aussi était attaché est
facile et les manies dont j'adore ce
truc je paul dewandre et au bout de 25
lors elle m'a dit bon on est un peu en
barque et le jeu j'ai pas demandé prix
j'ai rien dit et c'est le type avec
qu'ils étaient qui lui a demandé en
partant il est au fait comment comme
dans le noir il m'a donné le prix j'ai
fait faire un virement et voilà j'ai
fini par lasser les gens fut très très
longtemps alors je vous propose peu
oublié son nom
et franchement ça va beaucoup
d'importance moi j'ai acheté les oeuvres
j'ai rencontré des hommes
eh ben j'ai oublié leur nom c'est pas
très grave parce que je suis je vis avec
leurs oeuvres
vivre avec des oeuvres c'est vivre avec
des êtres c'est pareil donc bon temps en
temps il ya des ajustage affaire et bien
sûr il m'arrive encore très souvent de
changer les obliger d'endroits les
objets que je dégage
j'ai plus envie de les voir ça fait trop
longtemps qu'ils sont là où quelque part
il me donne pas la satisfaction que
j'attendais il ya des objets d'art qui
quelque part avouent leurs faiblesses
assez rapidement et cela je m'en
débarrasse voilà on vit avec des oeuvres
d'art comme on vit avec des humains
[Musique]
grand amour parce que ça buren c'est un
des premiers buren c'est un million du
début des années 70 on est donc 16 ans
avant le scandale des colonnes de buren
et le travail avait elle déjà cette
cession de deux lignes verticales de
couleurs toujours le même
bon j'adore ce que tu viens du moment de
la vie de collectionneur j'ai acheté ça
très tôt sont souvent très bien ce que
je faisais sans savoir pourquoi je
l'achetais l'époque burim sait même pas
comment ça s'écrit v personne se met
d'ailleurs ma collection ne s'inscrit
pas dans l'histoire de l'art c'est la
collection d'un homme libre et je crois
qu'elle marque au fil du temps
l'évolution le de mes goûts et de mes
orientations face à l'art contemporain
mais n'a aucune prétention
elle est je dirais qu'il est surtout
marquée par une grande liberté
[Musique]
il ya ça qui est très physique
ça c'est immense artiste ça merde
comment il s'appelle
c'est un grec de l'arte povera kounellis
le principe de la clé povera c'est de
représenter un certain nombre de venir
de caractère de notre société de manière
la plus pauvre et la plus directe
possible
donc voilà un peu du charbon ont pu
faire un peu du bois et allons-y
autant je me fais très peu aidés dans
les achats et les acquisitions autant je
me fais vraiment aidé dans les
accrochages c'est le plus compliqué et
c'est ce qui prend le plus de temps et
quelque part c'est aussi ce qui est
amusant d'arriver à trouver l'objet dans
le bon endroit dans les bonnes
proportions dans le bon reflet dans les
bols lumière il faut que tout concorde
[Musique]
quand vous achetez un truc vous savez
pas encore ce qui va devenir
mais quand vous marier avec lui au bout
d'un moment
eh ben vous le transporter jusqu'au
moment où voulez vous le mettez
théoriquement dans son lieu de
destination
mais l'expérience prouve que en fait on
continue à changer toujours accroché des
oeuvres c'est pas facile et c'est très
excitant et c'est ce que j'aime dans
l'art c'est quelque chose de très vivant
[Musique]
alors ça c'est le césar radical et c'est
pas une compression et le disait
lui-même
c'est une voiture qui donc écrasé dans
le sens de la longueur et non pas et non
pas compressé en cubes et je veux dire
pour moi ça a été un peu l'aboutissement
de son travail et son oeuvre c'est c'est
un clin d'oeil à un regard assez cynique
jeté à la société de consommation et du
tout l'humour je dirais et l'adresse
l'agilité de césar
warhol ça rien à voir warhol
j'ai trouvé samedi a plus cherché c'est
tellement longtemps mais j'ai trouvé ça
complètement par hasard j'ai dû payer
salle de prix de 3 me repose toi ça
c'est un coup de foudre
voilà le type même de choses que j'ai pu
acheter comme ça en chine et c'est un
truc qu'on me demande à peu près de deux
fois par an tout le monde veut acheter
tout ne me vois là bas c'est vrai que
j'ai pris des machines heures et un
chignon c'est quoi c'est quelqu'un qui
arrête ses yeux devant quelque chose qui
l'interpellent
ça peut être un meuble ce peu importe à
un moment donné up votre vie s'arrête et
le processus d'acquisition ou d'envié de
désir
c'est fait pour une femme pareille le
processus mis en route et à partir du
moment où vous avez envie vous avez mis
vos yeux sur quelque chose dont
finalement vous avez envie c'est un
processus classique
parfois c'est de l'achat parfois c'est
de l'amour parfois c'est un coup de
foudre
parfois c'est dérangeant peu importe
mais à part du moment où vous avez
décidé de prendre contact avec quelque
chose encore eu quelqu'un bons procédés
se met en route et le procès des bananes
c'est effectivement l'acquisition par
tous moyens
mais l'acquisition
[Musique]
c'est clair que la troupe de l'argent ça
coûte plus cher qu'un la glisse a jamais
compris ans
enfin tout du moment vous vous laisser
entraîner dans un logique de collection
vous vous laisser entraîner dans une
logique de dépenses
[Musique]
puisqu'il faut parler d'argent
parlons-en la course une baffe toujours
quand on a n'a pas beaucoup ça veut pas
dire qu'on ne peut pas acheter d'art si
on peut pas acheter une peinture on peut
acheter une litho sur le bassin du taux
du post une repro si tu aimes la photo
tu es pas obligé d'acheter le tirage
original tâche et le tirage presse ça
vaut rien photo est la même donc ceux
qui aiment voir regarder et qui n'ont
pas beaucoup d'argent ils peuvent
accumuler et en profiter
pour pour éviter de rester dans un
microcosme etc est d'ailleurs notamment
le microcosme parisien qui est un des
pires
il faut pas que dedans moi je fais
partie du milieu de l'art depuis très
longtemps je suis toujours cité comme un
homme du milieu de l'art mais c'est un
milieu que je fréquente pas du tout
[Musique]
j'espère qu'avec la fondation cartier on
aura contribué à communiquer avec la
ville pas seulement avec la vie avec la
population mais les gens qui viennent
voir cette exposition qui s'appelle
d'ailleurs graffitis on est dans la rue
ce sont pas les gens qui sont déjà venus
ici et moi ça me ravit complètement
parce que c'était ça qu'on cherchait à
faire et c'est cette société qui avance
qui nous et qui nous fait peur parfois
il faut il faut aller vers elle et voilà
la marque que la roma est à la fois des
technocrates un peu les politiques et
beaucoup d'une seule une élite
et d'ailleurs quand vous regardez
l'histoire de l'art
le mécénat qui est vraiment a été un de
mes chevaux de bataille longtemps que tu
d'histoire d'élite c'est à dire le
mécénat et est religion inventé par les
médicis mais c'est parfois elle a été
apportée par les par les puissants pour
les puissants
[Musique]
c'est difficile de les collectionner
parce que c'est difficile il a cumulé
parce que c'est difficile de faire
coexister mais au bout du compte moi
j'ai décidé qu'il ya plus de cas est pas
de règle donc l'ancien le contemporain
le moderne
le meuble la peinture sous trop violent
finalement il faut les mettre en vrac
quoi et je les choses prennent leur
place avec le temps
[Musique]
à l'époque j'étais avec mon épouse je la
première fois qu'on est venu assister en
plein hiver en 1979 j'ai adoré elle a
détesté
et puis bon jarry on va continuer à
visiter des trucs et puis en juin je les
ramener ici
il vient un temps magnifique et là elle
a compris que l'on pouvait en faire un
endroit formidable
moi je pense que le collectionneur s'il
ne s'intéresse qu'aux grands artistes il
est con pour être très clair ça devient
un spéculateur ça devient ça devient une
victime du système et moi je suis à
l'envers de ça j'ai passé ma vie à
chercher des artistes nouveaux et john
mitchell par exemple quand j'ai acheté
j'ai connu bien certains milieux
collectionneurs elle n'était pas très
cher d'ailleurs
et ouais donc dans ma collection c'est
une des mes repères
c'est une grande grande non je ne me
lasse pas qui est qui est vraiment très
très convoité on a souvent proposé pas
mal donc non je n'ai jamais acheté
d'oeuvre chers c'est parce que c'est que
d'acheter un artiste cher et très
consacré donc j'ai toujours été vers
l'artiste jeunes ou d'artistes
talentueux mais encore un peu obscur et
franchement et je me suis souvent trompé
il ya des choses qui sont restées
obscures
ça empêche pas de les aimer j'espère
qu'il ya pas des idiots suffisamment
idiots pour n'acheter que du très grand
quoi même si on est très riches à un
moment où il faut il faut être aussi
très personnelle quoi il faut avoir des
idées à soi dégoût à soi hanoi a soit un
regard à soi on peut avoir une culture
bien sûr dollar parce que là c'est pas
n'importe quoi c'est pas sans règles
mais à un moment dans sa vie je lui
souhaite en tout cas
il faut qu'ils puissent faire des
erreurs il faut qu'ils puissent se poser
la question est ce que cet artiste est
aussi bon que je le crois c'est le
plaisir de la collection ce qui est
amusant dans une collection en fait
c'est la prise de risque la prise de
risque elle est permanente
elle est à la fois artistique et et
économique financière
on l
aux afficheurs ces précieux là et puis
signal au graphique bleu là c'est ce qui
l'a rendue célèbre
c'est moi je viens lui si pas beaucoup
malheureusement pas assez souvent et
partout j'ai des oeuvres il m'arrive de
passer comme ça des heures tout seul il
a regardé ma règle sur une passe et
autonome j'ai besoin de recharger les
batteries
parce que les oeuvres on les oublie un
peu et s'éteignent tout doucement dans
la mémoire et j'aime bien retourner
retourner sur les lieux du crime
un artiste a toujours une raison crémer
dentiste faut que ça bouffe comme tout
le monde ça a besoin de bouffer et par
les temps qui courent il n'y a pas de
sécurité sociale spécial artistes les
artistes sont collectionneurs et pour
une somme sont mal barrés il leur reste
que les musées qu'en général on peut on
pas beaucoup de sous et un artiste c'est
quelqu'un de très sensible très fragile
ils ont besoin de confiance ils ont une
reconnaissance donc voilà le rôle du
collectionneur c'est ça en général
d'ailleurs les artistes aiment bien les
collectionneurs pas seulement parce
qu'ils achètent parce que ce sont eux
mais ce sont des éléments de sécurité de
sécurisation de l'encouragement paul
[Musique]
quand j'ai acheté le château je suis
allé chez le notaire pour signer le
notaire très fier de lui monsieur paiera
vous avez trois hectares de droits de
plantation il paraît que c'était un
trésor et on a planté le pigeonnier qui
a connu un bon anti aujourd'hui le
pigeonnier du château lagrézette a été
planté avec ses droits de plantation en
[Musique]
alors là vous aimez vraiment un travail
je suis heureux à la fois indescriptible
est totalement unique
les quatre les quatre inventeurs et un
peu star de la figuration libre
combas boiron di rosa et blanchard ils
ce sont les lâchers dans cet endroit
mais littéralement lâché
il fallait vivre à une douzaine de
bouteilles de vin le matin en général
c'était alors consommation de la journée
ça vous arrange un homme et il faut
savoir qu'il n'y avait aucune
organisation
c'était le bordel en fait c'était le
premier qui paient cavaillonnais quoi
alors combat je me suis j'ai vu faire ça
une vitesse vertigineuse
il faut savoir que robert combas travail
de manière très particulière les
couleurs vous voyez là commence par sa
6ème et du blanc et du rosé mais du bleu
et du gris c'est ce qui va faire il
compose son truc
seulement en couleur et après par un
immense panneau noir très fin très mince
et qu'un pot et à une vitesse de
croisière à main levée il détourne et
tous les trucs noir que vous voyez ici
ça vient après la couleur
et pendant que robert peignait revers
qu'on va se payer là haut il y en avait
un qui faisait le coup en dessous je
crois que c'est di rosa qui lui fut tel
feu enfin voilà blanche à l'anus
rajoutez pas il s'est glissé entre di
rosa et combas et puis après boiron est
venu d'ailleurs vous voyez un certain
moment ça se mord un peu l'un sur
l'autre camp il ya boiron qui m'ont un
peu comme à saint lô et ça a été comme
ça tout le temps ils vous marquent les
cas pas d'ordre et un coup combat cela
est un coup bas rhin en eau le coup
suivant c'est blanchard
voilà ils se sont bien marrés et je
trouve que c'est une oeuvre pleinement
génial et là vous avez l'apothéose
vous remarquez le torne du chevalier qui
avec un très bon état et ça évidemment
c'était la pagaille sur la collection
chez moi c'est assez vrai que c'est une
manie c'est une vérole quelque part mais
c'est un peu particulier parce que je
collectionne des choses comme avec la
balle en argent et casseroles en cuivre
ou ou les trucs pour pour m'en servir
dans la cuisine de la grèce est ici par
exemple tous les plats qui sont là ils
servent une époque je collectionnais les
barbotti ces plats sont souvent en forme
d'espèces de légumes tas de trucs et ben
j'en ai moi aujourd'hui parce qu'on les
a pété les à laver dans un truc à
vaisselle puis avec le temps j'ai moins
de la bottine qu'avant mais je pleure
pas sur mes barbotine c'est pas grave
c'est le collectionneur normal c'est pas
le mec qui arrive cachette et qui repart
c'est pour une botte de radis et un
qu'on achète au bout d'un moment il ya
un lien qui se crée avec l'artiste est
quelque part vous rentrez dans son
circuit est invariablement vous racheter
des trucs que je pense forcément envie
de racheter mais il ya un lien qui se
crée avec un artiste
[Musique]
cesari on peut dire qu'ils habitent le
château saint denis était venu ensuite
il ya beaucoup d'hommes césar et si
jamais caché soit très gros
collectionneurs de césar
je me retrouve très bien dans son oeuvre
j'aimais j'adorais l'homme donc c'est
vrai que moi je vois derrière l'oeuvre
quand quelque part je sais ce qu'il ya
dedans
et alors il ya une petite plaque
ravissante très très très particulière
de césar qui est dans l'entrée du
château
et puis bon et allart l'arbre l'arbre
peugeot c'est un culture en forme
d'arbre en oui un peu sur leurs heures
qui est en fait la composition de
morceaux et de débris des peugeot qui
ont fait le rallye d'argentine
je pense que c'est une des oeuvres
majeures ici vaut rien d'autre et la
côte l'autre cocottes en papier et césar
que tu me cocottes en papier en faire
évidemment qui est très célèbre et web
qui fait partie de son univers ludique
souvenir de jouer de travail d'enfants
un peu
[Musique]
je crois qu'ils m'aiment bien les
artistes du genre tout à fait je
respecte énormément leur liberté en 27
ans de fondation cartier je n'ai jamais
demandé un artiste de travailler pour
quartier de participer à la création
d'un produit
je vais plus loin même j'ai interdit
avec laboratoire de le faire
j'aime pas les artistes qui commencent à
produire un peu je dirais un peu la tête
de clients pour s'enrichir et moi je
joue je paie cash avec c'est pas de
l'argent je joue cachet que j'ai très
souvent en cas du non ça c'est
franchement de la merde il faut pas le
faire parce que l'artiste
il est il était un être humain et à
partir du moment il se rend compte
qu'une recette fonctionne bien
ce couillon là il va tomber dedans il va
recommencer et ça devient de la
diffusion et ça il faut pas faut pas les
laisser sans marquer là dedans il faut
pas les laisser embarquer dans la
facilité dans la répétition
alors le gros problème des collections
c'est qu'au début on les suspend sur les
murs on les installe sur les planchers
ou parfois sur les plafonds mais très
rapidement vous vous surprenez à
construire des maisons uniquement pour
suspendre les trucs que vous achetez
donc en fait ça devient très dangereux
ça devient très vite très dangereux les
collections et en fait tout autant que
les sonars qui se respecte ce sont des
choses qu'on expose pas qu'on oublie on
oublie même de déballer et là il ya un
peu tout y est les photos il ya la
peinture la sculpture et un césar pour
cela le nu assis là il ya un seul mot
kieffer un grand et très beau qui
ferment et que j'ai pas encore déballés
et puis lier tout à chaud des photos des
gravures de la peinture
voilà je viens chez elle a beaucoup il
ya une très jolie photo en scène sa
présence une photo du 19e siècle de
venise photo photo couleur c'est john
batho pie ix à dali par bio z est une
photo célèbre voilà c'est à peu près ans
j'ai quand même un chien mangez pas trop
honte
c'est bien je suis très très sensible
hokuto amende et artistes j'ai besoin
d'artistes dans ma vie toujours j'ai
toujours eu depuis je suis tout jeune et
je crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est oui
complètement
ça fait partie de mon monbiot rythme
gérard garreau s'est emparé de ma
chapelle et franchement c'est bien là
vraiment faire un tabac au travail il
n'a pas fait une fraise qu'il a fait ce
qu'on appelle une indienne
c'est à dire une toile longues pattes
pas tendu pas enfermer dans un cadre et
gérard oui je peux ouvrir et s'est
régalé dans cette chapelle est resté
longtemps pour faire ça et il a fait les
trois vitraux de la chapelle
[Musique]
je sais qu'il a aimé faire ça il a aimé
cette oeuvre on en parle encore quand on
se voit et ça me fait penser il faut que
je le fasse venir si elle entend qu'il
va venu
[Musique]
c'est une grande photo je pense est
important d'avoir une collection de
photos importantes comme celles qu'on a
ici et ce travail du capa et évidemment
pas le seul à passer un géant
n'empêche que c'est la photo qui l'a
rendu célèbre qui l'a rendu éternelle
c'est vrai que moi je fais attention
quand j'achète des photos ou des oeuvres
j'essaie de prendre les meilleurs
j'essaye de prendre ce que je pense -
est le meilleur est le plus fort de
l'oeuvre et voilà je sais pas si j'ai
raison de le faire mais en tout cas
j'essaie de le faire
j'essayais de tirer la quintessence de
l'oeuvre de l'artiste
[Musique]
c'est une collection rare parce que je
suis un trouve alors qu'ils sont des
oeuvres originales sont des tirages
originaux
c'est très dur à trouver je continue à
chercher j'en ai 15
peut-être que je devrais en avoir 16 ou
17 je n'en sais rien mais ça fait quand
même maintenant dix ans que je n'ai
jamais trouvé un corps tout ce que je
n'avais pas et il faut savoir une chose
qui est amusant c'est qu'on voit ces
indiens alors dans leur élément
dans leurs costumes sur des rivières
dans des prairies sur les rochers aucun
indien n'est en fait vrai curtis faisait
poser les indiens il les faisait
s'habiller presque se déguisait ce qui
est quand même intéressant parce qu'on
est persuadé de tenir là un document sur
la vie et l'histoire des indiens
politique tout était posé
fabriquée déjà en 1899 1900 1902 trois
quatre cinq pas en ces années là je m'en
fous un peu de laisser des traces moi ce
qui m'intéresse bien sûr c'est que mes
enfants se retrouvent dans ma collection
je sais qu'ils s'y retrouvent parce que
quelque part j'achète rarement des
choses sur l'art en parler avant est de
plus en plus souvent maintenant je suis
pas je ne suis pas un homme soucieux de
la postérité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh